hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we'll be showing from this year's
Norway chess it is Aryan tari versus
alireza firuja it is the game from the
final round and you guys have requested
this one for a couple of reasons I'm not
gonna go into them uh not to spoil too
much so let's just check it out and then
we are going to uh once again check out
the standings so here uh tari has the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte E4
it is a place Pawn to C5 with Knight to
F3 D6 and now Bishop to B5 check the
canal attack against the Sicilian with
Knight to the D7 and here Castles by
tari we have Asus bile it is a bishop
back to D3 and now Pawn to E6 so all
been played before nothing new here upon
the C3 making room for the bishop so you
can advance the pawn uh Knight G2 F6 and
now Bishop the C2 with Fanta B5 and now
Pawn to D for soul standard Sicilian
moves nothing
um weird happening here going after the
E4 Pawn with Bishop to B7 with Rook D1
and now Bishop to E7 we have Pawn to A4
C captures on D4 C captures on D4 and
now uh Castle's valid as we have font A5
uh grabbing more space on the queen side
Rook to C8 and now Knight B to D2 and
here uh there is a game that was played
this year uh last month in the uh
European individual championship between
uh Alexander kovachovich and
played Queen to C7 and he lost that game
but here we have Knights the B8 and it
is now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
tired continues Knight to B3 we have
Knight to C6
uh the pawn is nicely defended and
attacked and now Bishop back to B1 uh we
have Queen the C7 and the bishop to G5
so both players still just putting
pieces on optimal squares H6 Bishop to
H4 and finally alireza strikes and the
center would Pawn to E5 now you could
Advance the pawn to D5 right away it's
not it's not a problem the Knight will
then come to B8 to D7 then probably to
C5 but he postpones it first Bishop to
G3 Rook after E8 and only Now Pawn to D5
and okay like we said the Knight will go
back Knight to B8 uh we have Knight
after D2 and now Pawn to G6 with Pawn to
F3 and Knight to H5 challenging the
bishop here Bishop F2 and knights the F4
and now you have to be a little bit
careful if the queen somehow finds her
way over to the king's side it could be
very scary so Bishop to B6 attacks the
queen queen to D7 and now Knights the C1
getting ready to kick away this knight
from F4 or trade Knight for knight uh
Bishop to G5 and now Knights the D3 we
we have Queen t7 while it is trying to
get his uh Queen over to the king side
Knights the F2 and now Knight to D7
getting the other Knight into the game
of course Bishop goes back to E3 you do
not want to allow Knight captures Bishop
uh Rook to C7 uh preparing to double up
on the C file and now Knight back to B3
uh and here all it is that goes for it
he plays Knight captures on G2 and it's
a really uh really fun move it can be
met with many different ideas a problem
with King captures on G2 is that you
just trade Bishop captures through
captress and queen to G5 check picks up
the Rook on E3 AMU you could consider is
Bishop to B6 uh you you say okay I'm
attacking your rook and your knight is
still hanging but this is uh
uh quite that quite a long Force to dry
I will show it because it's very nice
and nice therefore uh you give up the
full Rook on z7 Bishop captures on C7
and now you just make room for your
queen to enter the game and now after
let's say Knight to G4 you challenge
that Knight after lights it captures
captures and rookie two uh now you just
go Knights to H3 with check King G2 and
it's a draw Knight to F for checking to
G1 Knight H3 check and so on you have to
play King to G1 G2 in order to defend
the F3 Pawn otherwise Queen captures an
F3 so we would probably see a forced
repetition here instead Bishop captures
and G5 was played with Queen captures
and G5 and now Knights the H3 attacking
the queen and now all it is a forces of
trade Knight to E3 opening up a
discovery and also connecting nicely
with the White Queen on D1 Knight
captures and G5 Knight captures on D1 a
beautiful capture Fest Happening Here
Knight captures and F7 Knight captures
and B2 Knight captures on D6 and finally
as there is nothing more to capture with
the night you have to move the Rook to
f8 was played and now Rook A2 going
after the night night day at the A4 and
now Rook all the way to G2 putting
pressure on the G6 Pawn so King the H7
and now Rook the C1 offering to trade
Rooks with Rook captures on C1 Knight
captures and now Bishop to A8 as the
bishop is really uh harassed here by the
Knight and not a lot of squares for that
Bishop as the pawn nicely covers the C6
Square uh Rook to C2 now preparing Rook
to C7 once this Rook lands on C7 you
know it's not gonna be uh easy to defend
Knight a to C5 stopping this and now
Bishop to A2 and now okay you know that
the bishop now covers B3 Knight to B3 is
coming you wanna get rid of the Knight
and then play Rook to C7 how can Alias
stop this well probably best is to play
Rook captures on F3 but all it is a
thought that he needs to get his King
over
uh to the center uh quickly he played
King to G7 and okay Knight to B3 Knight
captures some B3 Bishop captures and now
King to F6 with Rook to C7 going after
the Knight and you can't move the Knight
there's no good square if play Knights
the B8 and then just Rook to A7 and
again the bishop is trapped the Knight
has uh no way out uh you lose material
here what you could play is Rook 38 but
this is such a passive move that uh you
don't have a move for the rest of the
game let's say H4 H5 King G2 King G7 now
comes Knight to C8 and how are you how
are you playing this there there's no
King to F6 uh Pawn to D6 is coming now
even this diagonal opens up and imagine
if you move the Knight let's say Knight
to a fade because you really have no
other moves uh let's say Rook to F7
Checkmate so even that's in the position
but okay King t7 was played by Reza now
comes Rook to d8 uh sorry uh now comes
at night to the C8 with the check uh
King to d8 attacking both Knight and the
rook and now Pawn to d69 nicely
defending everything Rook to F6 and now
you have to be careful Rook captures on
D6 is the threat removing the defender
of the C7 Rook so Knights the A7
beautifully stopping Rook captures on D6
but uh uh if you don't play Rook
captures on D6 what do you play there's
no move here for alireza just a
beautiful positional Masterpiece by tari
Rook captures and D6 was played because
there's nothing better Rook to see it
with check King to E7 and now Rook
capture 788 now that is upper full piece
but okay alireza will still try Rook to
D3 uh we have knighted the C8 with check
King to F6 and now Rook captures an A6
with check King to G5 and now Bishop to
D5 uh we have Rook to A3 uh King to F2
now uh going for King to G3 to take away
these squares from the black king uh
Knight the C5 attacking the rook and now
Rook the C6 attacks the Knight Knight
the D3 checking to G3 and Rook captures
an A5 and interestingly there is a
forced Checkmate in four moves here for
tari so feel free to pause the video and
to win the game for Aryan while I give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting it as
it was not played in the game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course Bishop to E6 uh
that's the uh sorry not Bishop to E6 uh
uh H4 was played in the game but the
move that uh should have been played in
the game uh was uh upon the H4 with
check that Bishop D6 of course coming
next and now the problem is how do you
how do you defend this uh King to H5 of
course this is the only move but now uh
as uh Aryan did play this he did not
continue properly he found the first
move of the continuation but now Bishop
to E6 is the move you have to find and
now the threat is Bishop to G6 Checkmate
so you can defend this uh you can to
defend this if you play Knight to F2
okay you can give up a night but it's a
silly move still dash of the G for check
night capture spawning captures with
Checkmate and if you don't do this if
you play G5 still doesn't matter Bishop
to G for his Checkmate as The Rook
covers the G6 Square in the game
something different happened Point H4
check into H5 and Rook the F6 was played
but also it was in this position on move
55 that alireza feature resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here and truly there is nothing more to
be done there are such beautiful
checkmates lurking here you would not
believe like I'm just going to show you
a fun one let's say you go Knight to F4
uh do you see the spectacular mate here
uh Rook to F5 with check you sacrifice
the rook and after Palm captures uh
there's really not much for for you to
consider here uh Bishop to F7 with check
and now Knight to G6 is the only move
you play Knight to E7 now the thread is
Bishop capture San G6 Checkmate so you
defended F4 check doesn't really matter
King H3 Rook A6 to defend but now comes
the spectacular Knights the F5 and there
is no defense against Knight the G7
Checkmate uh whatever you play with
let's say we finished the game with a
nice B4 move uh Knight the G7 will be
Checkmate so yeah I thought it doesn't
find the force made in four but there
are all sorts of force to Checkmate you
don't have to waste time uh finding the
the proper one so I have to work to F6
is a resign and tari does get his one
win in the tournament and um for those
of you who haven't seen it okay tari
still finishes last but he uh took some
pressure precious points away uh from
alireza firozai had all the rest of one
this game he would finish in in fourth
place so that's uh definitely a lot this
way he finishes in eighth place uh so
yeah very nicely very nicely done by
tari I've uh you want to check out the
live standings or the head-to-head
scores check out my previous video uh
the one uh well that I made before this
one uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it last game I'm showing
for Norway chess so uh that's it it's a
wrap I would like to thank David Kimura
David gasparian Ricky Johnson fighted
Sonic and Derek King for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whenever
girls happens in the Chess World so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day